le château du rivau melodia 50 km de
tours près de sainte maure de touraine
eh bien c'est la renaissance françois
1er henri de catherine de médicis ont
tous arpenté les allées de ce domaine
visites guidées maintenant
il a fière allure ce château avec ses
tours pointu son donjon et son joli pont
levis le château du rivau se dresse
fièrement au milieu des champs c'est un
château à la fois médiévale et
renaissance
ici on voit plus sur cette façade une
façade renaissance avec des décorations
autour des fenêtres à meneaux des
lucarnes qui sont décorées également et
on voit si on fait le tour de la cour
également de l'autre côté que le château
a évolué par la suite au xviie siècle
puisque via et un mur qui a été détruit
pour laisser rentrer plus de lumière
dans le château et dans la cour
également le château appartenait à la
famille beauvau on se plaît à les
imaginer festoyant dans cette salle où
un peintre flamand est un maître italien
se sont côtoyés il y a plus de 500 ans
et donc ici la renaissance elle s'est
adouci elle est devenue beaucoup plus
sobre et on a surtout travaillé sur des
points qui étaient pas des éléments
décoratifs qui était donc là les maîtres
maçons
voyez cette tourelle en trombe sa
prodige de l'avoir réussi parce que
c'est pas évident de de construire une
tour elle qui en surplomb sur le
bâtiment
au début du 16e siècle françois de
beauvau capitaine de françois 1er fait
construire des écuries royales dans la
cour
cinquante ans plus tard son successeur
gabriel de beauvau fera intervenir un
architecte pour créer ce bâtiment
novateur unique en france
aujourd'hui il reste ses traces sur les
murs qui correspondent aux
caractéristiques des chevaux vous voyez
le travail de stéréotomie des pierres
qui est très rigoureux et qui annonce le
grand siècle français on a des bandeaux
qui souligne la longueur des façades
on a aussi des canons qui montre la
magnificence de ces grands seignard au
retour des guerres d'italie
les fier destrier du roi pouvait sans
doute passer une retraite paisible au
château du rivau
[Musique]
nous voici à présent devant ce bijou de
la renaissance accompagné de caroline
mignot bonjour merci de nous accueillir
chez vous puisque vous êtes une des
propriétaires parlez nous un peu de ces
transformations qu'a connu ce château
depuis des années alors c'est un château
qui a été construit en 1442 par pierre
de nouveau le grand chambellan de
charles vii et on a la chance d'avoir un
château qui a été assez préservé puisque
le seul grand remaniement qui a eu c'est
l'ouverture des croisés et on a ouvert
le corps du logis parce qu'avant on
avait un château complètement fermé très
médiéval et à la naissance n'a ouvert
pour ouvrir les jardins pour donner un
peu pour éclaircir le château il donnait
beaucoup plus de gaieté lui et de
lumière on voit derrière derrière nos là
il ya eu des transformations c'était une
chapelle ici en effet on a une très
belle chapelle qui a été hélas détruite
par un propriétaire anticlérical au 19e
siècle et on a souhaité recréer cette
chapelle mais en chapelle de verdure
avec des rosiers et de la vigne
caroline vous avez grandi ici vous êtes
une enfant d'ici est ce qu'on peut dire
que vous êtes une princesse non non non
je suis loin d'être une princesse mais
c'est vrai que j'ai grandi là il faut
dire qu'on a fait 25 ans de rénovation
donc quand j'étais petit le château
n'était pas habitable
beaucoup de travaux c'était compliqué
pour vous de vivre ici ça a été
énormément de travail pour mes parents
surtout mai
énormément de travail et deux pour la
réhabilitation du château et la création
des jardins pascal jardin était
absolument vides il y avait absolument
rien qu'est ce que vous aimez
particulièrement ici au les jardins les
jardins les jardins et surtout le
conservatoire de rose c'est particulier
parce que on voit la période renaissance
on voit la période médiévale
vous préférez il ya une préférence
moreau le médiéval et sympathique parce
que ça évoque vraiment les contes et les
légendes
ça c'est différent des autres châteaux
d'abord parce qu'il ya un peu moins de
châteaux médiévaux dans la loire ici on
est sur un des châteaux les plus anciens
du val de loire et ce à la renaissance
est synonyme de léonard de vinci
alors on le connaît ingénieux le génie a
inventé plusieurs machines au hasard
l'une d'entre elles pour vous
l'hélicoptère eh bien non c'est l'heure
ni d'observateurs
si cet homme s'émerveille des paysages
du centre val de loire vue du ciel
c'est grâce à leonard raccourci certes
mais de vinci a tout de même inventé la
première machine volante de l'histoire
aussi appelé l'ornithoptère son plus
grand rêve faire voler l'homme
il étudie alors le vol des oiseaux et
observent leur anatomie pour finalement
donner vie à son projet en 14 soit 88
léonard de vinci place l'homme au coeur
de cette machine entouré d'elle
similaire à celle d'une chauve-souris
elles doivent être recouvertes de soie
fine pour créer une membrane légère mais
robuste
leur mouvement est due aux pilotes ils
actionnent l'appui à l'aide des pieds et
des mains pédales et tirent sur des
barres les helvètes et pivote nous n'en
savons guère plus les recherches de
léonard s'interrompent d'un ton la
légende dit qu'un de ses élèves serait
mort lors d'une expérience grandeur
nature mais sans preuve impossible
d'affirmer quoi que ce soit si ce n'est
que léonard a fait voler l'homme pour la
première fois de l'histoire
le voici à présent coeur de l'exposition
en hommage à leonard de vinci une
exposition qui mêle renaissance et
contemporain karine parlez nous un peu
de cela oui au château du rivau on
essaie de faire un dialogue entre l'art
contemporain et l'art médiéval et on
s'est rendu compte que léonard de vinci
avait énormément inspiré des artistes
contemporains
donc c'est ce qu'on voit dans cette expo
combien d'artistes ont participé c'était
il ya plus d'une trentaine d'artistes
qui ont réinterprété l'oeuvre de léonard
et la renaissance qu'ils ont soit fourni
des oeuvres qu'ils avaient déjà soit
créé des oeuvres vraiment pour
l'occasion combien de salles combien de
thèmes alors il ya cinq six sites salle
avec six thèmes les différents thèmes
donc ici on est dans une salle qui est
dédié aux femmes et on a dû le portrait
féminin mais on a d'autres salles comme
le drapé avec les thématiques du rap et
une salle avec l'invention puisque
léonard de vinci était un grand
inventeur ingénieur un peu fou on a une
salle sur l'autoportrait puisqu'on a
aussi des autoportraits de portraits
masculins
et puis l'anatomie qui était aussi
importante dans l'oeuvre de léonard de
vinci
cette salle vous ressemble
expliquez-nous pourquoi cette salle est
très importante pour nous parce que
c'est vrai que château du rivau c'est ma
mère et moi qui géreront le château donc
les femmes sont assez importante dans
l'histoire du château et en plus on
s'est rendu compte qu'à l'époque
médiévale donc les femmes étaient partie
prenante de la gestion d'un château
puisque c'est elle qui gère à tous
pendant que le seigneur était parti à la
chasse ou à la guerre ce qui arrivait
assez souvent comme vous aujourd'hui
vous occuper du château peut-on parler
d'héritage
aujourd'hui on peut parler d'héritage de
léonard de vinci parce que léonard de
vinci et la renaissance continue à vivre
aujourd'hui ils sont présents dans
l'oeuvre de la plupart des artistes
contemporains
on peut s'attarder sur cette oeuvre
aujourd'hui elle a des raisons du louvre
quoi s'appelle-t-elle comme ça alors
c'est une oeuvre qui est très
intéressante puisqu'on voit laetitia
casta qui qui regardent l'oeuvre de la
joconde
on ne sait pas qui regarde qui elle
regardait quel spectateur qui
qui est l'oeuvre ça s'appelle une mise
en abyme et c'est aussi assez important
parce que c'est la question du bo à
travers les âges donc le beau chez
léonard c'était là c'était la joconde a
une beauté énigmatique un peu folle et
aujourd'hui le beau c'est peut-être est
ici reste à la joconde
l'une des oeuvres les plus connues de
léonard de vinci et vous savez pourquoi
et bien pour son sourire regarder tous
les jours trente mille personnes se
bousculent pour la voir la joconde un
pouvoir d'attraction considérable grâce
à ça
le premier vrai sourire de la peinture
avant léonard de vinci
les visages représentés sur les
portraits ont tous l'air de faire la
tête à l'époque sourire montrer ses
dents ouvrir la bouche c'est vulgaire
réservé aux bouffons et aux prostituées
léonard lui va être le premier à casser
les codes car il a un objectif très
précis en tête
au cours de ces années de recherche il
découvre que finalement le sourire et
l'expression humaine la plus subtile la
plus ambiguë
en fait la plus riche de sens léonard de
vinci à l'oeil d'un scientifique et pour
que les sourires de ces peintures soit
hyper réaliste il travaille en
profondeur
il va même jusqu à disséquer une
trentaine de cadavres pour être au plus
près de la nature me humaine léonard va
même inventé une technique de peinture
secret pts superposer plusieurs couches
transparaître sur la toile pour créer
une vibration si l'illusion que le
sourire à nîmes
l'oeil ne fixe pas quelque chose d'un
contour très précis tout à l'air comme
vue à travers un peu un voile de fumée
et ça c'est ce qui va donner de la vie à
la matière picturale jusqu'à la fin de
sa vie léonard de vinci va pendre des
sourires du plus discret jusqu'à celui
carrément ambiguë de son saint jean
baptiste
[Musique]
prenons un peu l'air sortant du château
pour découvrir ces jardins des hectares
de jardin qui entoure la propriété avec
plusieurs particularités dont l'une
accueillir des oeuvres contemporaines
ses bottes vous rappelle sans doute les
bottes de sept lieues et bien non ce
n'est pas le cas patricia tout à fait
lucide ce sont les bottes de l'artiste
liant bourgeois et c'est un des loges à
nature puisque elle indique que la
société de consommation on ne nous donne
pas les plaisirs que la nature pourrait
donner et qui vaut mieux regarder vers
la nature plutôt que d'acheter des
objets manufacturés qui n'ont pas de
sens y at il d'autres oeuvres
contemporaines que l'on peut découvrir
au sein de ses jardins
oui il ya vingt oeuvres monumentales
tout aussi ludique les unes que les
autres parce que ce qui est intéressant
c'est de faire aussi sourire nos amis
visiteurs
les oeuvres elles sont à la fois
spectaculaires mais aussi elles font
réfléchir tout en les amusant en les
faisant sourire les enfants adorent
alors les parents sont ravis
quel appareil découvrir par exemple eh
bien on a un l'arbre bleu où on peut
souhaiter donc revenir au jardin du
rivau on a le port rouge du grand
artiste jean pierre raynaud on a le
collier de l'artiste du val de loire
céline turpin on a le à like america à
la main qu'à la x me d'un artiste bull
car cette fois ci on a des artistes de
tous les pays du monde aussi ici aux
rivaux combien d'hectares peut-on
compter de jardin il y a 6 hectares de
jardins dans ce domaine avec combien de
jardinier pour les entretenir
eh bien il ya cinq jardiniers et eyliac
souvent des stagiaires
il y à 14 au jardin ils sont chacun sur
un thème différent de couleur on a le
jardin jaune
on a le jardin blanc on a le jardin pour
on a le jardin rose on a le jardin rouge
on a le jardin mort visant tous des noms
de comptes
fait pourquoi patricia et bien parce que
pour moi ici c'est comme le paradis donc
j'ai envie de donner à nos amis
visiteurs de rêver et de rêver à ses
comptes qui les faisait sourire quand il
était enfant de leur donner envie de
voir la vie du bon côté et de voir la
vie en rose en rose est justement vous
en parler autre particularité de ce de
ces jardins patricia les roses combien
de variétés de roses
eh bien nous avons quatre cent soixante
quinze variétés de roses mais leur
spécificité c'est qu'elles sont
pratiquement tout parfumé et donc
certaines sont très anciennes comme
celles ci ce sont les roses gallic les
plus anciennes rose que l'on trouvait
autrefois en france ils ont été ramenés
des croisades leurs ancêtres par thibaut
de charlemagne
l'hybride et pour donner toutes ses
belles couleurs et puis on a des roses
plus modernes qui sont intéressantes
parce qu'elle refleurissent tout au long
de la saison on a aussi des roses qui
sont comestibles
on a toutes sortes de rosé on peut il
faut vraiment les découvrir sur place
quatre cent soixante quinze variétés 476
dimanche puisqu'une nouvelle variété de
rose va être baptisé génie léonard mais
on en parle juste après avec fabienne
thibeault tout de suite regardé une
activité qui a eu lieu le 18 mai dans le
château regarder la soirée aurait pu
s'intituler anachronique partie un grand
saut en basket et en jeans jusqu'après
le moyen-âge léonard de vinci aurait été
emballé car côté invention les
princesses ont des smartphones et les
gentilshommes des appareils photo
numériques
généralement nous moi je suis en tenue
de jardinières oui déjà du château donc
là voilà je suis chauffeur poids lourd
en fait un grand grand écart là pour le
coup
en coulisses les habilleuses à billes et
chacun devient un autre observée plus
tôt
le rêve se réalise
et l'on retrouve une âme d'enfant alors
le maître à danser donne le la et la
machine à remonter le temps est en
marche
[Musique]
ce couple de bordelais ne rate jamais un
bal c'est leur passion leur plaisir
ghislaine et jean-michel peuvent
parcourir des kilomètres pour s'habiller
raid ans et s'était passé mais voilà les
miens suivront mari mais le plaisir
c'est de se retrouver ben disons dans un
entrepôt dans les couloirs du temps on
va dire comme les visiteurs pour le
dîner des fous et les mêmes qui ont
déclenché les guerres picrocholines au
pays de rabelais juste à côté
et puis on retourne à la danse
robin joly mène le bal aura bien sa
place double 12 pts imoula en tournant
et on se nomme les membres à 12 ou 30
secondes avec quelques mots c'est très
facile de remettre dans le droit chemin
de la musique de la danse ce soir on
avait deux sortes de danses il y avait
les danses collectives qu'on appelle les
danses de côté qui sont des branly
peuvent être double simple de poitou
morgue est coupé et il y avait des
danses plutôt de procession qu'on
appelle des danses de marche comme la
pavane ou l'allemande un dj en habit
prend le relais
[Musique]
comme pour un retour en douceur au 21ème
siècle
au bout de quelques rocks il faut
quitter les robes renaissance trop
dangereuses pour l'exercice
la fête continue tard dans la nuit
et cette belle parenthèse passe comme un
conte de fées fabienne petits bouts nous
a rejoints dans les chats dans laisse
dans les jardins de ce château vient
thibault vous êtes une artiste de
renommée internationale à lucie paix à
la comédie musicale starmania
mais la procédure si vous êtes là
aujourd'hui c'est en votre qualité de
marraine marraine de la rose génie
léonard exactement au mot nord du titre
de commarin ne met un rouge chez ni pour
quelle raison vous avez bien une idée
pour quelle raison parce que j'aime les
roses peut-être et que j'aime lyonnais
aussi vous connaissez bien la vie de
léonard de vinci la faire tout va bien
j'ai beaucoup lu neigeux les laisser un
peu me parlait aussi pourquoi racontez
nous un petit peu parce que léonard fait
partie des 2 du projet musique12 fresque
féerique sur la région centre val de
loire les avait écrit sur lui vous a
inspiré une chanson que je vous propose
d'écouter écouter sa musique de richard
hounslow rance
à milan et à rome j'ai peint et dessiné
et surtout
vente et des outils pour les hommes un
sourire de femmes et vous parliez de moi
de cette renommée
dans si vous saviez les choses dans ma
tête et beauté dans ma main et toutes
les idées
jeter sur le papier caché dans mon aide
vous sauriez que jumale d'être ci veut
aimer
[Musique]
choisi par pays
on vient tout le monde
on
[Musique]
à
mais c'est ainsi
pour
au monde
[Musique]
pourquoi avoir choisi léonard de vinci
fabienne d'abord c'est le génie de
l'humanité il l'a profondément marqué la
région mais le second à une valve ou un
répit parce que dans ce spectacle que
nous écrivons avec au charbon ou via des
personnages issus de la terre imaginaire
et nick historique
il vous inspire vous personnellement bah
je pense que c'est un homme qui préserve
encore grande part de mystère et il a
tellement fait pour l'humanité c'est un
tel génie que franchement on ne me
reconnaît qu'il revienne léonard de
vinci les châteaux le patrimoine en
général fait c'est très important pour
vous oui c'est passionnant moi je suis
québécoise et quand j'ai découvert la
france
eh ben c'est tout ça qui aidera main un
présent de ce pays savent où vous vous
battez pour défendre ce patrimoine là
oui moi je m'occupe beaucoup de races
agricoles menacées ses balais pas mais
oui donc je petite fille de paysan et
j'aime tout ce qui est terroir et bons
produits la nuance est ce vous donc ça
sera quand est ce que vous allez
inaugurer cette rose baptisée génie
léonard et des actes dimanche dimanche à
laurent lors de la fête de la rose une
grande fête de la rose où ils vont merci
beaucoup merci à bienne thibaut une
grande fête de la rose qui a lieu tout
le week end au château de rivaux alors
bien sûr
l'inauguration le baptême a lieu
dimanche à 16h20 pouvez vous pouvez
venir au château de rivaux tout ce
week-end c'est la fin de cette passion
valence gentil un peu les vous allez
même chanter c'est la fin de cette page
spéciale jt de la renaissance au château
du rivau la semaine prochaine on se
retrouve à chaumont sur loire c'est à
vous mélodies merci beaucoup lui si pour
ce beau partage rendez-vous donc
vendredi prochain pour une nouvelle page
renaissance